let's now see if we can convert a larger
decimal representation to binary so
let's say that we have the number 114
and this is its decimal representation
see if you can pause the video and
rewrite this in its binary
representation so I'm assuming you have
at least tried now so we can work work
on this together so as always we just
want to decompose this into the sum of
powers of two and you can always
decompose this is any number into a sum
of powers of two and we can once again
just remind ourselves the powers of two
two two zeros one two to the first power
is 2 2 to the third power is 8 2 to the
fourth power is 16 2 to the fifth power
is 32 2 to the sixth power is 64 2 to
the seventh power is 128 and that gets
us large enough we've already gotten
larger than the number here so let's see
114 can be re-written as the largest
power of 2 that is less than or equal to
that is 64 so we can rewrite it as 64
plus what's going to be left over 64
plus 50 now we're gonna have to rewrite
50 as the sum of powers of 2 and let's
see 50 is going to 50 is thus it can be
re-written as see the largest power of 2
that is less than or equal to 50 is 32
so we can rewrite it as 32 plus 32 plus
what is that plus 18 and now we have to
rewrite 18 as the sum of some powers of
2 well 18 the largest power of 2 that is
less than or equal to 18 is 16 so this
is going to be 16 and then 16 plus 16
plus 2 and lucky for us too I guess not
that lucky we have to do this a good bit
2 is a power of 2 2 is a power of 2 so
we can rewrite this 114 is equal to is
in the gift
myself enough real estate here is equal
to 64 plus 32 plus 32 plus 16 plus 16
plus 2 plus 2 I've just written 114 as
the sum of powers of 2 and once again we
can be used as 1 64 plus 132 plus 1/16
plus 1 2 now we're ready to really write
this in binary so let's just write the
different place values so remember this
is the ones this right over here is the
ones place value or the ones place I
should say I'm actually let me do this
in a different color so this is going to
be this is going to be the ones then
we're going to have the twos then we're
going to have the fours fours place then
we're going to have the eights place
eights place then we're going to have
the 16s place tells you how many 16s are
in this number then we're going to have
the 30 twos place 30 twos place how many
32 s are in this number and then you're
going to have the 64 is place 60 fours
so how many ones do we have here well we
have zero ones how many 2's do we have
well we have one two you're going to
have one of something or zero there's
only two digits if you're dipping in
binary now we have no force no fours
here no eights no eights we have a 16 we
have a 16 we have a 32 we have a 32 and
we have a 64 so in binary the number 114
in decimal would in binary would be
written as 1 1 1 0 0 1 0